نحن سوف
نعم
أستغرق حوالي ستة أشهر وأكثر
ستة أشهر
حسب جودة القبعة
مع أكثر أو أقل من تلك التكلفة بين 25 و
تصل إلى أكثر من 25 2000 دولار
ويعرفني الكثير على أنني الأفضل
حرفي من العالم
رقم
اسمي سيمون جابي لي نهاية
أنا أهدي للحرف ما هو
نسيج قبعة من القش
لقد تعلمت منذ أن كان عمري 14 عامًا
دعنا نقول أن القيام بهذا الفن ما يقرب من 40 عامًا
[موسيقى]
لقد عرفنا جدي وأنا وهم
تحدثوا أن والدهم كان معهم
عندما كان لدي ولد فقط
بدأ في الحصول عليه
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، لا يبدو هذا عندما يلعبون
أنه كان نسيجًا حريريًا أشعر بذلك
بهدوء
أعتقد أن هذه القبعات هي
من الأفضل اعتباره في العالم لأن
جودة القش والأهم من ذلك
لنكون هذه القبعة
وضع مادة كيميائية لتبييض القش أو
أعتقد أن كل شيء طبيعي ، إنها عملية
منذ فترة طويلة أن عليك أن تبدأ الأول
من بريد السلام إلى التجفيف
المطبوخ
حدد القشة لتكون قادرًا على صنع ملف
قبعة لتجميع
الصليبي الذي يسمى الأخ الصغير
سلطعون
وبعد ذلك يمكنك أن تفعل ما هو
المزاد الذي تعرض للضرب يغسل
تسويتها بحيث يمكن للعميل بالفعل
وضع
أنا فخور بعمل هذا
وظيفة
كل صباح أستيقظ ، حسنًا ، دائمًا
أفكر في عملي في القيام بـ
الأشياء الجيدة تبقي على قيد الحياة
تقاليد شيء بالنسبة لي جدا
المهم ولكن بعد ذلك أعطني الله
مدى الحياة الصحية لتكون قادرة على الاستمرار
صنع هذا الفن
[موسيقى]